[Music]
hey folks
welcome back to the dark horse podcast
live stream number
52 q and a segment we
are ready to go we got some questions we
got some questions we'll find out if
we've got the answers we got some cats
we got a dog
yep it's all happening yep it's all
happening all right we will start with
three questions from the last episode
let's jump right in
in turkey venezuela north korea total
submission to the boss is the common
trait
of all high-level political cogs a beta
trait makes them alpha males
and influences the gene pool as well is
there long-term significance
yeah absolutely um now i
don't want to claim that i necessarily
know whether the
basic assumption here is right but i
will say this is
a mechanism that one sees
in hierarchical authoritarian structures
where effectively
the top of the pyramid uh has an inner
circle
that he takes care of which is protected
by the next layer and so you have
you know this pyramid structure and so
anyway i think what the questioner is
pointing to
is the fact that submission is the key
to dominance if you submit
the thing that's very powerful then you
end up very much more powerful than you
would otherwise
yeah um so that's an interesting
interesting point and it's you know it's
it's
absolutely universal and strongly
hierarchical structures
right and it's it's true it's true
between it's more true between males
and other species that are strongly
poliginous as opposed to monogamous
polygyny being the form of polygamy in
which one male
tends to monopolize the reproductive
output of many females
as opposed to the inverse which would be
polyandry
and you know i think these again like
you
i can't speak to whether or not the the
basic assumption here is true although
it
sounds right to me um this will be
um this is a decent analogy to a
strongly poliginous structure in which
the alpha male is allowing some other
males to hang around but
ultimately he has the last say well he
does and he doesn't the reason
that he grants any access to any anybody
else is because he needs
allies to keep him in power and so the
point is it's basically a uh
a concentration of power phenomenon that
in which
um the wise move is for each
tier to share as little as possible with
the next tier in order to
retain its position yep next question
what else do you have in common what
else do you have in common
with uh dj
[Music]
donald trump aside from censored online
pro-science but skeptical of
establishment scientists pro-lab leak
hypothesis
against racism antifa crt new wars the
disk etc
there's no end to the number of things
that we have in common with him
from bipedal we're bipedal we've
got respiratory enzymes in common
digestive enzymes morphological
structures at every possible scale
mesentery mesentery to beat the band
yep so many things i don't even know
what this question means i think the
idea is that we are supposed to confess
some deep
alliance with this person that we are
ignoring which is not it's one
it's one of two things it's either you
know confess your your
cryptic deep alliance that um
you know you have but you won't admit or
realize that you have this deep alliance
that you haven't yet seen
and so you know we see both of these
things um coming at us
uh the first one is just not true all
right you know it's not it's not that
we're obscuring some
deep alliance that we're that we're
obscuring we've said often a number of
things that we think
that he has done that he is doing that
are
are valid and valuable and have been you
know in in some cases you know much
much better than or just like outside of
the domain of anything we thought
he might have done and then some places
where he exactly matched
our expectations anyway in terms of not
doing a good job at all
and but you know the second the second
thing
i think is a more interesting potential
critique
or request for investigation which is
if all of these things are true about
him and uh what
about what he thinks about what you
think and the fact that they're aligned
why don't you see yourself either of us
as more aligned than than
we say we are well again i feel like
this
is there's just a trap here okay so
there's some structure out there
and it hates him and it hates us and it
hates us for different reasons but he
would love to portray us as the same
right i do not you know there are times
when the enemy of my enemy is my friend
but my sense is okay you've got two
different crime families am i
aligned with one because i'm skeptical
of the other
um no the fact is uh
we need good governance we need
corruption to be
uh reduced from the massive influence
that uh it has over our system to a
manageable level you know yes it'd be
better to get rid of it completely but
that's
uh unlikely but in any case i i don't
know
why why him i i i don't want any part of
this those those of you who
have settled on him as the vehicle
are placing us in a kind of danger to
address a different kind of danger and
sorry no i'm interested in the long-term
well-being of
the republic and the planet and that's
going to require us to put decent people
in office they exist
so let's address the system that
prevents them ever from getting there
any evidence for something like autism
occurring in other ape or male species
do you think psychological adaptations
like this could have emerged very early
on in the evolution of consciousness
um this is a tough one because
um you're going to find analogs for a
lot of things
how close the analogy is is going to
vary a lot
i think we've got a lot of novelty in
our system that's causing
this disability which means they're a
tiny number of species that are likely
to have
similar patterns those species will tend
to be
ones that are domesticates and therefore
are also experiencing a huge amount of
novelty
um or just affiliates um you know
there's a
i can't that's not quite the right word
there's a word in ecology conservation
biology for
organisms that do well in our presence
even though we aren't domesticating them
yes things like
pigeons and um crows and rats
i don't think we'll see it in those
creatures because those creatures
are subject to the same malthusian
dynamics where there's a limit on
resources and so
if you're in the crow population yes
your niche may be humans
but there's a limit to how much that
niche can feed and so it tends to favor
those that are
fully functional and so in some sense
the fact
of human civilization
removing the limits on resources
that people can feed themselves from and
also
are domesticated creatures means that
there is a kind of
ecological tolerance that doesn't exist
outside of that very small number of
creatures and i'm reminded
i used to teach um about two-headed
snakes
i remember one from when i was a kid in
the la zoo there's a two-headed
rattlesnake and my point was
that um we are not responsible for
explaining two-headedness
as an adaptive phenomenon because
we always see it as a one-off instance
but anyway because i've been tracking
two-headedness and the internet has
gotten
uh so much larger i now see a huge
number of examples of two-headed
creatures and the basic point is yeah
this happens all the time
in captivity and you never see it in
nature why because a two-headed creature
lasts about six minutes you know and so
um so anyway the point is
it is arguably marvelous that we have
room for a lot more
diversity with respect to things like
these parameters
but it doesn't mean oh these things are
in and of themselves great relative to a
dire ecological situation that most
creatures find themselves in and so
i think you know it'd be interesting if
we found these things in other
populations but i don't expect it
yeah there is a question um about
whether or not autism
might not uh have you know be a in
trade-off relationship with something
that actually
renders i i the the many
actually high-functioning autistic
people that we have interacted with and
and been friends
with um have seemed to have some very
special
skills as well that come along with it
and you're not at the level of savant
you know these these aren't people who
were you know truly dysfunctional in
other areas of their lives
um and it you know it often seems like
the savants come with you know extreme
extreme dysfunction elsewhere um
whereas two-headedness is just an error
right and i would say you know for me
the right analogy
for the two-headedness discussion is
more like intersex
where you know it certainly happens in
the wild but it is an evolutionary dead
end
and pointing out you know having all of
the internet
available so that you can point out all
the many people who are intersex does
not in and of itself
render that condition and adaptation or
you know render sex non-binary for
instance whereas autism
is potentially something a little bit
more interesting
with with adaptive value even oh i'm
that's exactly what i'm saying is that
it does
have adaptive value but only in a
context where it's not being
forced up against the requirements
of a normal ecological niche so yes
there's no question i mean you know but
blindness also will reveal certain
things right we have
many extremely gifted blind musicians
presumably there's some connection there
um so anyway yes extreme deficit can can
force
extreme talent right yeah but it doesn't
mean we should be looking for
uh blind creatures out in the world um
because the fact is it's a devastating
loss when
you've got predators and things yeah
yeah all right
okay our question from the discord
server this week we always get one a
week
it comes off the discord server for
those of you who are on there
curious as to your thoughts on the
stoned ape theory the idea that
psychedelics were a part of the
development of human consciousness
is there any weight to this hypothesis
has there been any other analogous
coevolution between an organism
and a drug that proved beneficial in
developing certain traits
yeah let's put it this way the stoned
ape hypothesis is
uh not as bad as the naked ape
hypothesis
um but i think it's it's naked ape the
same as the swimming area yeah the
swimming pool yeah they
evolved in in shallows right yeah um
but what i would say is
late i would say there is a close
relationship between humans and
psychedelics and it has a lot to do
with consciousness we see it in too many
populations various kinds of
experimentation it's not always
psychedelics sometimes it's things like
sweat lodges or
starvation or whatever else it is that
causes those same
phenomena to be unleashed and low-level
psychedelics like marijuana
right but the
idea that that's what triggered us to
become special rather than having become
special
this thing which to any other creature
would be
dangerous is useful to us as a hack is i
think
um flipping the causation on its head
the fact is
very same thing that we were talking
about in the last question the fact that
we are not
constantly faced with predators and uh
in need of spending every uh minute with
reference to its ability to generate
food resources means that we can afford
to
disrupt cognition in ways that sometimes
reveal things that our conscious mind
wouldn't otherwise know about
i would say in particular
psychedelics takes stuff that is all
from your brain
that is not available to your
consciousness and it moves that border
so that you become conscious of those
things
and you know increases plasticity and
things like that so
anyway your normal cognitive state is
adaptive and hacking it is also adaptive
and that's what's
going on here absolutely and to the
final part of the question i don't know
of any other um co-evolution between
organism
and a drug a molecule or a whole species
that have that looks like
the latter part of human evolution and
psychedelics
if the question is about cognition i
agree with you that disrupting
um cognition by introducing analogs of
neurotransmitters
i don't know of another version of that
though i won't be shocked if
there are some but the ones
you know there are lots of things like
um
your poison frogs for example your
poison frogs both in the new world and
the old world to different groups of
poisoned frogs
which lose their toxicity when they stop
eating their
normal diet which strongly suggests that
they are picking up
something from that diet a precursor
yeah
apparently it's a precursor molecule in
the ants and the mites
of their native diet that allows them to
synthesize
these uh these neuroactive
alkaloids uh that are deadly toxic to
vertebrates including us yeah so that's
very different
from the normal way that
food and our own physiology interact
where you basically
eat proteins break them down to their
constituent
letters effectively and then write new
words out of them in this case
these creatures are borrowing a peptide
presumably
and building on it um so it's not
it's not what you're asking about but
it's no that's actually that's super
interesting it's
um it's a different level of breakdown
and rebuilding and
totally far afield and you have no
reason to think that i actually spent
any time thinking about this but when i
was
writing um the science fiction that i
was working on as evergreen was
imploding but before it went public
um i was specifically thinking about how
how humans who had successfully gotten
to another planet that did have organic
life but had obviously
a totally different evolution of life
would make
would make food and whether or not you
would have to have you know the
biologist
on on staff break down into effectively
elemental forms and then rebuild or if
there was
a a less fundamental level of breakdown
depending on exactly what the the
informational molecule
on this different planet might have
looked like and i i didn't
i wasn't thinking consciously about my
frogs but i think that story
of course informs a lot of what both of
us think about
how nature some of the myriad ways that
nature manages to make function
out of the things that one ingests yep
all right first question from today
i live in colorado noah writes there is
a unity party on the ballot here
obviously not unity 2020. who are these
people
did you have any communication with them
also thank you both for sharing so much
wisdom and spreading the tools you used
to gain it
who are these people brett i'm not sure
i've spent have you heard of them i've
seen unity in various places
i assume most of it is the fact that
we've landed on
a resonant idea because it is a resonant
idea
um i mean even biden harris is using it
well
here's the problem you never know
whether or not
that was them discovering oh goodness
there's something out there claiming
that we're influence peddlers and that
it's unity
and uh the way to deal with that is just
to
steal the concept of unity and use it as
our own and
make it impossible to track or whether
you know they hadn't noticed at that
level and the fact is
you know i think we can see in things
like the um banning at twitter
that as much as unity was a small
movement it was detected the threat
came not from the size of the movement
it came from
the resonance of the message and the
fact that anything that was
non-ideological and was therefore
empowered
to call out both sides was recognized as
a hazard
that it would not surprise me if they
saw unity on the horizon
and decided to get in the road by
claiming it for themselves
right
our global company's compliance manager
made the following unsupported claim
racism exists in the workplace as
microaggression
she then recommended finding allies by
speaking to compliance teams legal teams
or even calling the ethics hotline
i'm afraid to be accused of racism if i
question this topic
what questions can i ask to be
respectful of these very important
issues in the workplace
but still determine whether we are
headed towards a dark place of
unintended outcomes
well i think if it were maybe i might
actually
track down that paper and we have put a
link or we will put a link to the paper
that we talked about in the first hour
associated with this video and i might
actually deploy that and i might say
here's the problem with your search for
microaggressions
is that it threatens to find them where
they aren't yeah
now that's that's that's really good and
then um also the
the tools outlined in helen and james's
book pluck rose and lindsay's book
cynical cynical theories again cynical
theories
um yeah
that's a short answer but i guess we
spent a fair bit of time talking about
this in the first hour
all right next
question where are we there we go how
can healthcare college etc be a right
when no one has the right to use the gun
of the state to force others to pay
their bills
it sounds a liberal fire police etc are
local not federal
and even rape and murder are handled at
a state level
now wait a minute there's sleight of
hand in that question there is sleight
of hand in that question but i can't
quite put my finger on where it where it
happens
um it is in the phrase
no one has the right to use the gun of
the straits
state to force others to pay their bills
this sounds true but is false
and the indication of why it's false is
found
in fire police etc are local not federal
so your point
is these indicators that we all agree
suggest a right of the state to collect
taxes to do things that we
think are important like putting out
your house if it's on fire
it does not extend to the federal
government but that's a completely
arbitrary
division that you've drawn no i mean the
fact that fire and police are local and
rape and wood are handed at the state
level that's still that's still
governmental
regulation and control and a
demonstration that yes we actually do
have you can't decide to opt out of
uh fire suppression you're gonna pay for
your share of fire suppression and you
will get it if your
house catches fire and you should be
grateful because it's a bargain
but what i would say is look there is
a whole set of um
false insight in this case it lives on
the right
and the false insight has to do with
well wait a second i
i made that money you're taking it in
the form of tax this is theft
right i mean steph let's just call it
what it is it's nonsense the fact is
that's not where the flaw is we actually
do have a right to figure out what is in
our collective interest
we have to do it responsibly it can't be
done you know
uh in a corrupt fashion but
there are certain things which are you
know
necessary and the fact is you're
benefiting from them constantly
right if you were really that rugged
individual that that idea
depends on you being you would be
spending
all your time trying to figure out how
to get yourself through the winter
how to put away enough food so that you
didn't uh
starve recreating your roads right you
would be
uh generating power somehow these things
be fending off the
uh you know the warlords who decided to
charge you a tax that wasn't legitimate
for your ability to go from a to b
all the things that you would be doing
if you didn't have the state
doing them for you or facilitating that
they be done for you
would be taxing you at a much higher
level so
the question isn't do we have a right to
take resources from you to do
things in our collective well-being the
answer is is it being done
well is it being done sparingly right
yeah um so well i just the final thing i
would say is
you are part of an implicit deal and the
deal has
failed but it didn't fail at the point
that
we collectively decided to take
resources that you personally were
largely responsible for generating for
our collective well-being where it
failed is
in exchange for taking those resources
without asking you whether you
want to provide them or not you are
due certain things from the entity that
is our collective uh our collective
force
right you are not in a position to be
a hunter-gatherer anymore society
decided you are required to be a
civilized person
and to do civilized stuff and to give up
the rights of a hunter-gatherer and that
means that society
owes you the other side right it owes
you an obligation to do the job well
right to do it carefully to make sure
you're getting a good deal
and we're not doing that so civilization
is in breach of contract but the breach
of contract
isn't in the idea of taxation it's in
the idea it's in
how well society is living up to the
obligations that come
as the other side of that equation so i
agree with all that i thought that was
an excellent soliloquy
um i do think there's something
additional here though
um you know the idea of paying your
bills so i think the person writing the
question has effectively
you know they just list two things
health care in college
um and i think the the insinuation there
is that these things
are choices that individuals make and
that other people can choose not to make
and therefore because there's individual
variation in how much you might want
health care or how much you might want
to go to college or how much it might be
necessary for you to function in society
it should not be something that is state
funded
and uh you know what things should and
what things should not be considered
universal rights
is obviously a big part of the question
that we need to be
a big part of the conversation that we
need to be having and a big part of
the sorts of things that right and left
will tend to disagree on
right actually and in fact of the two
examples that you provide
a i think it's telling that school isn't
on the list that we have so
long since accepted public education at
the k-12 level
as something that the federal government
is paying for
it doesn't even show up here anymore and
the fact that
so much of k-12 schooling is terrible
should render it something that we
should be considering okay you know what
maybe we need to really really improve
these things
rather than continue to assume that
because the government has paid for them
for
i don't know what it's been a hundred
years um they will continue paying for
them in
into perpetuity but ex expand
the idea of how much schooling should be
should be paid for by the government
into college at one end or
here in portland actually on one of one
of the local measures we voted on was
uh universal uh preschool
and it's easier to see that actually
maybe those aren't things that the
government should be guaranteeing for
people and that that's certainly where i
fall like i i don't think
that preschool and college are universal
rights or should be paid for by the
government compare that to health care
which there are good models in the rest
of the world and
actually everyone does have a body and
everyone
does need to have a healthy body in
order to live their best um
and and most productive life
that said so much of health care is so
broken
just as broken as education is for
somewhat different reasons but for some
of the same reasons because
market forces and perverse incentives
have rendered most of the practitioners
in sway to the administrators and in the
case of medicine the drug companies
such that it's like i want
universal health care for americans so
we don't have to be paying through the
nose on a monthly level for health care
that i think is terrible
but it's harder to argue for that when i
know that most of the health care that's
out there that's at least sanctioned by
the
insurance companies is not very good
well
i would say that part of the flaw in
that is
the idea that rights is the correct
um mode to be thinking of these things i
don't think
health care is a right but i think that
in a circumstance where you have
a society that generates the kind of
surplus that we do that it is
in our collective interests to give
health care so to everyone now you've
answered the question then
now so what the question actually asks
is how can it be a right and you're
and that's this is sort of why i just
did what i did because i think
you were not answering the actual
question what you said was all
correct in terms of what you believe and
what i believe as well what many
liberals believe
but the premise of the question is how
can it be a right well as you just said
you actually don't think it is a right
right however you will note
that i do have a right that grants me
the ability not to answer the question
yeah
um and i'm the one who pays indeed
indeed um yeah so uh not there are
rights
these things that are shoehorned into
rights are often not but it doesn't mean
that it's a bad idea in fact the real
question is
are we better off creating a risk pool
that includes all of us does that make
health care cheaper
more available in a society better when
people have health care
guaranteed than when we vary in our
access to it
and the answer i think is clearly yes
yep
next question what would be an example
of a failure of capitalism that free and
voluntary association itself can't
remedy
if monopolies are bad wouldn't monopoly
on force
as in the government be worse if
corporations care about profit
hit him where it hurts most their wallet
uh externalities okay i'm not sure i
understand the question but
you you go what would be an example of a
failure of capitalism capitalism that a
free and voluntary association itself
can't remedy
so if i make goods
and i pollute the atmosphere
in so doing and my product is therefore
cheaper than another product
of exactly the same quality where the
company was
treating its waste responsibly and the
company that is treating its waste
irresponsibly will out-compete the one
all else being equal it will out compete
the one that is behaving responsibly
and the consumer would be foolish not to
buy the cheaper product because they
don't actually clean anything up due to
a tragedy of the commons
so in effect externalities
require us to regulate
in order that the costs of keeping the
environment clean for example and there
are
dozens of non-exactly environmental
analogs to this
but in the environmental case the cost
of keeping the environmental
the environment clean is
born in the correct place rather than
borne by those
who are the most careful
so anyway i would just say the more once
you understand things like tragedies of
the commons races to the bottom
uh prisoners dilemmas the more you will
see that
many many problems require a
governmental solution now i would argue
to be as light-handed as possible
but those light-handed solutions are
required otherwise you get
perverse incentives all the way across
the system
do you have thoughts on joe rogan's
podcast featuring tristan harris
i believe that particular podcast should
be seen by as many people as possible
from a strategic standpoint pewdiepie
would be the ultimate signal booster
love your work be well so
you're going to be having tristan on um
of course
very soon i at least have not seen
rogan's tristan uh podcast i did listen
to
tristone's conversation with sam harris
uh which was excellent i mean we
so we interest on our friends and uh
he's
he's terrific and he's really sounding
the alarm on
some very important things right now
have you seen or watched i think i saw a
clip i certainly didn't see the whole
rogan interview so i can't speak to it
directly but yeah i would just say
um i believe tristan has understood
some things very deeply and much earlier
than most people and that he is
uh sounding the right alarm and anyway i
look forward to talking to him about
where we are and what we do about it yep
do you see do you see a link between the
political left and right
and lumpers and splitters for example
left advocates for equality and
spectrums the extreme being
postmodernism
if so is the current madness biological
or psychological
talk to professor frank ferretti um
so i'm gonna let you take the first part
of this i will just say that frank
ferretti whose name i
feel like i'm probably mispronouncing um
we met him
when i uh talked at oxford two springs
ago
uh he he is terrific and definitely a uh
a kindred spirit
um hungarian i think now emeritus
um some university in great britain
um doing really excellent work um
excellent sociological work
actually um but to the first question do
you see a link between political left
and right and lumpers and splitters
so you immediately saw something there
well lumpers and splitters this is
clearly a phytogenetic systematist of
some kind
at least um or a taxonomist i mean
who knows but i can't look i have a
feeling you're pointing to something i
don't spot right away what the analogy
would be
it may dawn on us later but
i would say i tweeted something that
resonated really well with people
yesterday i think and it was effectively
that if you
i said painting with a broad brush
because you have to if you
divide the world into political left and
right i am solidly
on the left but that is not my team my
team
is composed of those on both sides
who understand the vital role being
played by the other
and lots of people seem to think this
was a sensible formulation i'm certain
that it is
but in any case i mean i think i think
it's about as good an answer to your
question as
you could get down further
oh you've just been at it today haven't
you um
let's see there it is yeah yeah so just
like you said
divide the world in the political left
and right i'm solidly on the left but
this is not my team
my team is composed of people on each
side who understand the vital role
played by the other
yeah yeah and it's it's interesting it's
amazing how
uh this actually works as a very good
um broad brush litmus test
that i hear a lot of people who are just
pulling all out for
red or for blue yeah and there's almost
no headway you can make with them
it's the people who um realize that
there's a
dynamic tension here who you always make
headway with right it's like you find
the person downstream of that discovery
you find a reasonable person right
many cats like most pieces of mammals
become
lactose intolerant as they grow older
would you expect
lactose tolerant cats be more prevalent
among those segments of human
populations that also remained lactose
tolerant
love from poland marson um
yeah yeah clearly so just to
flesh out the logic a little bit that's
good i like this question we
have an enzyme that break breaks down
lactose
it is the lactase enzyme we all produce
it because
mother's milk has lactose in it and so
we need the enzyme
to break it down in cultures that don't
have a dairy tradition
you don't produce this enzyme beyond an
age where you would
be in contact with mother's milk
in populations that have developed a
dairy culture
we create this enzyme throughout life
and it is often
in fact maybe always sensitive to the
presence of milk in the diet so that is
to say if you're eating milk
your body detects that you are and it
produces this enzyme to break down the
lactose
in it and in cultures where there is no
dairy tradition the ability to
upregulate it in adulthood
is uh either weak or non-existent and so
but it also seems that there is a an
ability to affect
during development whether or not you've
upregulated the production of lactase so
just anecdotally and i believe there's
some research that backs this up
anecdotally we have had the experience
of
traveling for months at a time in places
where we weren't really exposed to dairy
and upon returning home finding
ourselves less capable
of of digesting dairy and then it
quickly returns and it returns
discovers that you're you're ingesting
uh milk over its products
so if if that's true if there is
um in an individual that has had lactase
upregulated such that it continues to be
produced in adulthood
um which you know the one the one black
box here is has that happen in cats at
all
but if that's true um we would expect
yes that in for instance dairying
traditions
um that you know cats that live near
milkmaids are likely to retain the
ability to digest
uh lactose throughout adulthood because
if they do they're gonna be really much
better fed
absolutely and the other comparison is
not just within domestic cats
but domestic cats and their close wild
relatives you would expect
the close wild relatives to be like
populations that don't have a dairy
tradition
where it just simply gets turned off and
doesn't get turned back on
um and domestic cats would be variable
yeah
very much in an analogous way as human
populations just as you suggest
yeah okay next question with another
name that i will butcher the
pronunciation of do you have thoughts
about janus varafaka's
theory that uncontrolled capitalism
erodes democracy
by incentivizing would-be quality
leaders away from politics
so i don't know this guy i don't know
this thinker but um if that description
of the idea
uh is accurate if that thumbnail of the
idea is accurate
it it sounds savvy yes
um and it's one of the problems so again
if that sentence is an accurate
representation then it's certainly
likely to be right but it is not an
unsolvable problem in other words
if you recognize that this was causing a
corrosive
effect you could correct for it and this
is
it's one of the puzzles in how you would
build a
more functional stable 2.0 version of
our system
is how you would uh incentivize
the um the presence of the highest
quality people in the mechanisms
where their insight would be most useful
yep
why does the news not tell us the truth
do you think the west is dying a slow
death
why does the news not tell us the truth
because
it is an irresistible prize to those who
have
the need for it to propagandize us and
so the problem is it's it's kind of a
it's an arms race where it would always
be a great idea to have
news but the value of having there
be nothing that functions like news is
so high to so many
that we can't find it and
um anyway
yeah that's another puzzle that has to
be solved because we're going crazy
okay um
sorry where are we humans are very bad
at analyzing risk
but frequently think in terms of luck
what's the deal faulty heuristic or
useful
fiction um
i don't know that humans are bad at
assessing risk
it may be that they are bad at
consciously understanding
risk and it may be that they are getting
worse in
novel modern circumstances where they
are not exposed to sufficient risk
at young ages where the risk can be
mitigated
right but i also think that we
misunderstand the problem because we
over
understand individuals as somehow
important and
the thing that has made populations
important has been
the fact that the individuals in them
were disposable so
you know you need somebody to cross the
horizon on a ship in order to discover
that land mass which means you need
somebody to
badly estimate the risk of doing so in
order that they're full enough to try it
um so in essence i would argue
we are built to
lie to ourselves about risk because of a
deeper calculation about the necessity
that we confront risks that are
very frightening um so something like
that yeah
there is a biological analogy to the
manuscript that you referenced
receptor upregulation i.e when the
ligand
is in low concentration cell increases
sensitivity to the ligand by increasing
receptors
oh that's good yeah that's true yeah
that's absolutely right
yeah critics claim that we overreacted
to covet 19
given the virus's 98 survival rate
aren't overreactions
meant to be successful vehicle operation
has a higher rate should we roll back
safety
standards yeah we almost certainly
under-reacted um even if
elements of what we did were positively
incoherent and are still
positively incoherent right this
obsession with signaling to each other
via masks when we're outdoors
is nonsense and our inability to
behave ourselves enough to drive the
virus to really low levels
or to upregulate
testing you know to generate high enough
quality tests and get them widely enough
distributed that we could actually
effectively see where we were and behave
in a rational way
it was all very incoherent but um
we could have done a lot more for a lot
shorter period of time
and gotten a lot better result and
instead what we kind of did was split
the difference between two warring
political factions versions of things
which
in essence was pretty close to the worst
of both worlds yep it created a
tremendous incoherence as you say yeah
yeah
are you supporters of regenerative
agriculture and permaculture have you
gone into it from an evolutionary
standpoint
guest suggestion joel salatin and i may
be mispronouncing his name but this
question from
crystal um i love this so joel salatin
uh was profiled in the omnivore's
dilemma by michael
pollan which is one of one of my
favorite books
and he i believe ran the farm
southeast seaboard virginia someplace
like that
where he had pigs and chickens and he's
growing veg
in a i hadn't remembered that it was
being called regenerative agriculture
regenerative permaculture but
um there's there's a lot here that is
uh that is valuable it's not
clear how well it scales is the one big
issue you know how how many people can
you feed
uh with this kind of model on the other
hand the number of people that you can
feed
with a spray it all
and monocrop everything model
has so many externalities built in and
the regenerative agriculture
permaculture model doesn't
so we you know this is another
conversation that we need to be having
if we could be if we could not be
talking about how everyone is racist
when we're not
and and get back to some of the
important questions
how it is that we move forward with good
healthcare
good agriculture good education are some
of the top issues i would say
good heather and brett
please come to live in miami a truly
diverse city with great weather and law
and order
all right recommendation you want to
replace
law and order which is now a very
divisive
dude it's the it's capitalized it's the
show
i think no you don't think no i think i
mean law and order
the president has been invoking all over
the place and we all hear that
gavel thing i thought he was talking i
assume i don't know i was talking about
the show which i assume is still on
because it's been on forever well it
will be on forever
even after we're gone and by we i mean
humans
um the thing that i would say
is law order is now one of these
partisan dog whistle things
and that's bad yeah right um rule of law
that's the way to do it in the patriotic
unifying american
form uh so yeah we haven't spent
i i had a 14-hour layover in miami
a few years ago on my way to lead a
study abroad trip
actually my first one in ecuador um
before we went down together
um and i kind of say it was a very weird
experience
uh you know i stashed my bags and i went
and i thought i'm just
i did try to seek out the weirdest part
so i went to i took the jitney or
whatever it was to miami beach
and i got there i was there like seven
in the morning and it was already just
weird there was a like a topless female
volleyball tournament going on
and there were cruise ships going past
and lots of people
sipping improbably architected
cocktails at seven eight in the morning
and
i think i actually i took a picture i
took a couple of pictures but one of the
pictures that i took was from the
the bathroom in the place where i got
breakfast
which had on the inside of the door the
women's bathroom
a picture of a topless man with a dog on
him
and it wasn't sexual except it was
clearly like hey women this is this is
what you want this is what miami offers
you
and the whole thing seemed very very
weird to me so i gotta say that's my
sense of miami
is very very weird all right i have the
sense that it is a very
normal wonderful place
please just continue to follow us
heather and i will hash this out
and eventually we will find out the
truth of miami even if at a distance
um yeah now in terms i mean i
actually we have we're trying to make
plans to get to the keys
um and then kobet happens so
i'd be interested to explore miami which
is i guess the jumping off point for the
keys at least
why would you not recognize the
positives of the last four years no new
wars
no terrorist attacks peace agreements in
the middle east
oh absolutely we do recognize them the
problem is
you're well i don't want to say you but
the implication of the question
has to do with the individual driving
this and you know look i would say if i
was talking to chomsky
i would say how can you make this point
in light of the fact that you've made
this
point in prior years about these
adventure
adventurism abroad and the wars that
we've started needlessly
and so yes trump is a mixed bag but the
problem
the problem is the man's
temperament the driving force
the obligation to politicize everything
is lethal and what i would say
i hope you can hear this what i would
say
is those of you who see the positives on
that side and are tempted to look past
the negatives because there are
positives
and want everybody else to do the same
thing have to understand that you are in
fact
inviting in a person that is
a package and the package
is very dangerous
very political very uh
temperamental and that that
is not an acceptable solution so am i
telling you don't vote for him
no i'm telling you you don't have a good
option
on your ballot period that i can be
certain of so
is it wrong to vote for him absolutely
it is as
would be everything else you might do
but why you expect everyone
who can see some of the positives that
have occurred in the last four years to
embrace the whole thing i i don't quite
see it
and you know uh i have no patience for
what the other side is doing either
and you know i i take no position on
which one
is more lethal i can say in portland
there is reason to fear the
um in portland the lesser of two evils
argument is clear actually
well the lesser of two evils argument on
our local ballot
that's why i said in portland well but
in portland we're still voting on the
president which is the subject of this
quest at the national level it is not
clear
which is the lesser of two evils in
portland for mayor
the lesser of two evils argument is
clear well even when the lesser of two
evils
uh is clear in a federal election it's a
very different puzzle
that's that's true that's aside from
what i said i actually think and i think
you know many people who are watching
don't inherently know that this is
actually
maybe it's not what you believe but i
actually and you know i have heard this
from a number of
of friends this time around it's really
not clear to me
which you know put aside that we live in
portland for the moment because that
does
skew things somewhat um if
if you lived in a place that doesn't
look like it might head off into
complete anarchy
after the election given some results it
is not clear to me
which of these two clowns is going to be
worse for the country
at the federal level right it's just not
clear to me so the lesser of two
evils arguments doesn't make sense for a
wait a minute why are you contributing
to play with the duopoly
reason but it also just doesn't apply
here because i actually just
it's not clear to me which one is lesser
and no that doesn't mean
that um i'm cryptically for trump or
that i
actually have trump derangement syndrome
and can't see anything positive he says
neither of those things are true
yep i agree yeah um
two quick two more quick things here and
then we'll go to the next set
what episode you consider your best that
showed the most foreknowledge of events
and turned out to be true
but i have no idea actually on that one
just no idea
um six hundred thousand so this i just
i'm reading it because i don't know what
it means
um except i have some sense of i'm gonna
mind read a little bit 600 000 cancer
deaths protected by the cdc this year
just because it's halloween doesn't mean
you look intelligent with a mask on
so this strikes me as someone uh one of
these people who thinks that masks don't
protect against kovid
and also that kobit isn't a real threat
and therefore
why would you protect yourself against
it even if it was useful and this
600 000 cancer deaths predicted by the
cdc this year
um and like hey that's actually lower
than i would have thought given that
over 200 000 have died from covet that's
actually
that actually makes me think covet is
even more deadly than i thought
and um cancer isn't covankova isn't
cancer and it already existed and it
will always exist
so i don't even see what the relevance
here is except that
this is someone who imagines that they
have the right answer
and the rest of us who think there's a
virus out there that's doing harm or
buffoons of some sort two things one
the cancer thing cuts the other way
because in some sense this is something
that emerged
from my work on senescence and cancer
years ago
in some sense as you cure various causes
of death
whatever causes you haven't yet cured
take up the residual so the fact that
cancer rates are going
up can mean something bad it can mean
you've got toxins in your environment or
it can mean something good which is are
they going up though i don't know that
they're going up i'm not saying that
my point is a high number
for the number of cancer deaths is in
part because we have dealt with other
uh causes of death in this case covid
is now a new cause of death it's going
to cause the cancer rates to fall
because people are going to die of
something that isn't cancer that's not
good
so yeah what i'm saying is you have to
be cautious in
figuring out what these numbers
and oh yeah that's important that's
really good what i think
people need to understand is that people
like us
who full well understand that this is
not nearly as deadly the case fatality
rate is lower than we feared
right that's good the immunity that is
apparently generated by having been
sick with kovid is less than we would
hope especially the antibody
based immunity that's very worrisome
that means people are getting coveted
twice
right so and third the long-term effects
of it
are worse than anyone was talking about
or imagining in the early days
absolutely and they affect uh
tissues that you really should be very
reluctant to surrender
longevity you know if it's your liver if
it ages your liver by 10 years probably
it doesn't cut anything off most
people's longevity
your brain oh that's very different and
it does appear that people who have had
this uh sickness even mild cases of it
have um cognitive damage or
brain damage uh that is detectable
so in any case all of those of you who
think
you know how to evaluate what the cost
is
of things like lockdown and masks and
can evaluate it relative to the cost
of economic
recession etc there is not enough
information available
nobody can evaluate these things
properly and so that means that you have
to take
seriously people who are informed and
get the argument but disagree
um so anyway keep tracking it
yeah okay first question from the
current hours super chats as a
disagreeable person i am mostly drawn to
disagreeable people
and most of my long-term relationships
are with disagreeable people is it a
pattern
how much of disagreeability is genetic
versus cultural thanks love you
yeah this is uh a great question i i do
think that this is a it's a it's a great
test case because you would tend to when
you hear the word disagreeable you tend
to think oh well
i would like to not have disagreeable
people in my life on the other hand
disagreeable people are exactly the
kinds of folks
who will tell you what you need to know
who will stand up when
it's not uh simple safe or convenient to
do so
and so there's something to be said for
do you have enough disagreeable people
in your life how disagreable should they
be
obviously people who are disagreeable
for no purpose other than being
disagreeable are a problem
but um you know there's a question about
what you're trying to maximize
and uh
genetic versus cultural um yeah i mean i
would say it's
going to be almost all cultural yeah or
at least
all accumulated post-birth
right it didn't come to you in your
genome which you know doesn't
necessarily mean cultural it can mean
that you you know
you can learn it from being in the
wilderness and
realizing how things work and then it
can manifest in the social context but
yeah
um so hope you liked my article right
i'll fight you naked i did i read it i i
did enjoy it
thank you given the tribal nature of
humans are we biologically capable of
world peace
if not what form of global cohabitation
should we be striving for
yeah we're capable of world peace um the
question is how you stabilize it and we
humans are clever that's kind of the
point of us
and what that means is what would you
have to know what lessons would you have
to reinforce that people
understood that what they were inviting
by engaging
in a behavior like violence
was going to make them worse off rather
than better off and how would you
disincentivize
those who sought to profit
[Music]
by engaging in violence it i would say
it's a design problem
and it's one that we know is solvable
because
you could make this argument at every
scale that we've already solved it on
right in other words we have a very
peaceful society which yes we are
threatening to take apart for no reason
whatsoever
but nonetheless it has been you know the
sort of pinker
level point about how safe it is to walk
down the street amongst people who have
no genetic investment and you're
continuing to breathe
um right that fact means
oh well we used to be more violent and
now we're less violent and it works and
you don't question it because it just
you know it's the water you swim in and
the question is can we make it the water
we all swim in well
unfortunately we've got to deal with
some folks who don't agree that's the
problem but if we can
overcome the folks who don't agree that
it would be great to be peaceful
um then we have to remind the people who
say they agree what they're agreeing
with
and especially if they're in power and
they have the ability to
cause the folks who don't agree to sit
down and shut up
we have to force them to agree with
violence if necessary
the the leaders i don't know
i was being ironic but i mean at some
level this is the problem it's not that
there's anybody we have to be violent
against but to the extent that there are
those
people and populations that don't
subscribe to the idea
that the objective is for us to be able
to live
together harmoniously and minimize
violence
we have to be prepared to use violence
to protect that principle
yes ghost stories
what do they do for us how to explain
sightings when different people have the
same experiences independently without
other
without prior knowledge of other stories
are there any ghost stories that you
would like
to share um
yeah it is halloween we failed to
mention that it is halloween
did you not know that um let's put it
this way
last night when i took the dog outside
so that she might relieve herself she
told you that tomorrow was halloween
the full moon reminded you that it was
halloween i reminded myself because i'm
just
that with it um so it did occur to me
last night yeah that it would be
halloween and it just didn't
manage to occur to me today that we had
actually gotten there but
look it is undoubtedly the scariest
halloween ever am i right about that
i think so okay um ghost stories ghost
stories yeah
what do they do for us well first of all
there's the whole idea of ghosts
right ghost stories are one thing once
you've got the idea of ghosts then you
can
borrow it for you know spooking your
date or whatever it is but
um i mean why do people go to horror
movies
it's a bond i think i've got ghost
stories like sitting around campfires
telling ghosts i do too but my point is
it's close
kin whatever you know going someplace to
be scared
right like a movie isn't that far off
from
uh tell me a story that's gonna spook me
while we're sitting around the campfire
it's all
closely related stuff yeah um
so i would just say a
the idea of a spirit world is
pretty clearly i would say a literally
false metaphorically
true phenomenon in which there
is a cohesiveness
that derives from the continuity the
ephemeralness
of people is not all that healthy
right that the fact that somebody exists
and then suddenly they don't exist
means that we are constantly in an
upheaval of what the dynamics
are and you know the rat thermal
ceremony that you've talked about
uh in madagascar where the
the dead are brought back disinterred
in physical form um
as bones to hear
a recounting of the recent history of
their group
tends to create i mean just think about
it this way
if your aunt
is the reason your aunt on your hand
your aunt
is the reason that you
retain civil relations with
your cousins because you're fond of your
your aunt
and your aunt uh not wanting to
disappoint her as a motivation and then
she's suddenly gone
oh suddenly your reason to be good to
your cousins is lower
unless you're gonna have to explain to
your aunt why your aunt
why her absence uh is
um has caused this change in your
behavior so
the point is you are actually it's a way
of keeping the ancestors alive
well and it but you know what it also is
sorry uh is
it may actually relate again to that
paper that you showed in the first hour
with regard to seeing something with
more frequency as it decreases in
frequency so with regard to sightings i
mean i know
i know after my father died i
occasionally saw him in a crowd
and he wasn't there yep obviously he
wasn't there he was dead
but i had you know because my because my
parents had loved to be close to us
i had been in this lucky position of
seeing both of my parents
you know multiple times a week at that
point for years and suddenly no more
i began to see him places where he was
not and i didn't call it a ghost
but i but you know i was i was i was
doing the pattern recognition thing i
was
looking for the the man that i loved who
had been very present and was suddenly
completely absent so
you know some of it is also going to be
that yeah i agree that's a very good
point and i think
that may well have something to do with
it and i've had that experience too you
know even
with your grandfather probably yeah my
grandfather and you know i remember it
with some
pets oh yeah is in some ways
uh just a really good test of this you
see him going around the corner
right and going around a corner and you
know you know what happened it's like an
optical illusion where you're like
hypersensitive for
you know to see that creature and it's
not there and
you imagine it oh i remember this yeah
yep um how much time are we at zach
okay let's do let's do three more how
about that good
um okay that's 600 000 cancer deaths
guys back here but we already addressed
that
so um i think we don't have to go back
there
can you explain all the election worries
to a non-american
why does someone have to concede don't
you just count the ballots and run the
college
run the college uses scare quotes um
well first of all
the concession thing is a
um what would you call it it's a um
courtesy
uh you know maybe that's the wrong term
but it's somewhere in that neighborhood
what is a concession yeah okay conceding
the election
when enough ballots have been counted
that you know you're going to lose
is gracious it um
it bookends the arduous nature of a
presidential election
yeah it uh reduces the
hazard of your followers not
um accepting this and so
uh you know and you know we've seen
recent examples where it didn't happen
you know um so
anyway you know you do just count it and
it is the electoral college
and um that's the way it actually works
but a system in which we all understand
that
the civility of the citizenry is
desirable and that we should recognize
that our political differences
do not uh contradict
all that unites us that is essential and
we are losing that that's part of why
this election is so damn scary
yeah is that we are frequently now
looking into the eyes of people who
under other circumstances would be
comprehensible to us and we are unable
to fathom them because they are saying
things that make no sense you know
yeah noam chomsky saying trump is the
greatest
criminal in human history bernie sanders
suggesting
that we vote for a
supporter everyday anti-fascist yeah an
everyday anti-fascist who
when she is anything but lightly invokes
stalin
right these things are unimaginable and
yet here we are
yeah so that's an incomplete answer but
hope it gets you somewhere what are your
thoughts on the ethics of veganism
um the ethics of
well i can say that um
almost as a rule vegans are among the
least moral people i've
ever in no that's not true um what can i
say about the ethics of veganism
let's put it this way we have a
sustainability problem
if your veganism is motivated by
a desire to live more lightly on the
earth
i think you're making a mistake about
how we get there but
i understand the impulse and i regard it
as
you know it's it's a mitzvah as what we
would say
in jewish culture so anyway it's
positive but it's symbolic
as far as i'm concerned for reasons of
game theory
you know which i've described in the
personal personal responsibility vortex
that your personal behavior
is um not the place to solve these
problems they have to be addressed
systemically or you will actually
paradox
paradoxically make the problem you're
trying to solve worse
at a personal level i would say that
unfortunately the problem is
the more extreme you are in trying to
solve these problems
through your personal behavior the more
difficult it is to be properly nourished
right so vegetarianism creates a problem
for vegetarians veganism
all the more so because it eliminates a
bunch of the things that you would use
to substitute for the meat
so probably from the point of view
of doing the most you can for a
sustainable world
while not compromising your health a
small amount
of consumption of
meat and animal products is the way to
go
oh there's one other thing here that i
should say there is one way in which i
regard
vegetarians and vegans as way ahead
morally speaking and that has to do with
the ethics of the way animals are raised
right i i find as many people who've
thought about it do
the um the conditions
in which factory farmed animals are
raised
just impossible to accept this is not
our right to do this to animals and the
fact that we do this
basically out of everybody's view so
they don't think about it too much makes
it worse not better
and we are lucky enough to be in a
position where the meat that we buy and
bring into our home to cook for
ourselves and the animal products
are not raised in those conditions but
that requires a certain income level
and i know of almost no restaurants
where you can reliably expect that that
is true so if you ever eat out you
aren't
um you you are not being wholly
consistent in
in what might be your efforts to be
thinking about the conditions in which
animals are raised for
our consumption and even if you manage
to source all your own meat
humanely um there's still a lot of
animals suffering in appalling
conditions and so at some level
it's our obligation to collectively
address that
but the the hard point for people to
swallow
is ethically raised animals that is to
say
animals that are raised in a way that
they are
healthy and not
existing in a that they are not tortured
by life
they are not living in a feedlot or a
cage or something like this
animals that are raised in such a way it
is not immoral in my opinion to
raise them and consume them if they are
humanely raised and they are humanely
slaughtered and they are kept healthy
that can be done in a way that doesn't
involve a moral compromise
and that is in fact what we should be
heading for but that meat will be
inherently more expensive
and we have to accept that we would be
eating a lot less
yeah assume trump wins and we make it
through
what realistically could we be facing in
2024
if biden wins what are the chances that
trump would try again in 2024
we need unity yeah
them some some frightening prospects i
yeah i i don't know i i mean we really
we very much hope that unity 2024 is a
is an
active uh force long before
uh the election of 2024 starts ramping
up
yep and we are we are accumulating the
puzzle pieces to make it
a more effective uh movement going
forward
so yeah we do need unity and we need
unity whether we have unity the
organization the movement the entity we
need the concept
to change our behavior towards each
other and for it to carry the day
because
frankly we got a lot of bums to throw
out of government
yeah we've got a lot of people who've
been betraying us
through their corruption yeah so i
actually want to drop to the bottom too
because one of them is just apropos we
already talked about and one of them is
particularly timely and we'll come back
to a few others that we missed next time
please help my brother and his wife
tested positive for covert 19.
they have two young children under 10
who tested negative
what should they do well it depends on
what your options are yeah it depends on
what your options are if
you know if if they live
in a town with close family whom they
know are being careful and there is any
possibility
of basically having someone else do the
child care
until they test negative that would seem
to be
the right move but that is almost
certainly not possible
yep most people do not live in a
situation where that's going to be
possible yeah i agree it's very unlikely
that they
would have those options yeah and two
children under 10 they're not old enough
almost certainly to be doing all of
their own food prep themselves
yep and so there's a question about
whether they test negative
family member can take over their care
without getting themselves sick it's a
really serious situation
yeah so uh yeah you know quarantine
as much as possible to keep the kids
from getting sick and you know the
the the virus deniers will say well but
kids when they get sick they don't get
that
sick um they then spread it to other
people
who get sick and we don't know the
long-term effects
that is that is the truth at the base of
of all of these things
one more it's just a comment um with
regard in response to
the question about or the suggestion
that we consider miami
you seem like st petersburg florida
people heather the dolly museum just
reopened and brought plenty rule of law
los esperamos hashtag keep the republic
all right well cool we're looking to st
pete's i don't think i've been to
petersburg same page no i don't think i
have either um
anyway sounds warm it's
it's gulf coast i think um and it's it's
panhandle gulf coast if memory serves i
don't know my
my my florida geography that well cool
well if travel ever comes back maybe
we'll
visit florida oh boy i'd go just about
anywhere just about anywhere
yeah yeah so um
we i think we'll be back on wednesday
for our next episode
um probably because uh we may know more
things about the future at that point
and we may not yeah i mean we will
definitely know some more things
about the future just by virtue of being
there at that point
ah we may know we may not know any more
things about
that at that moment's future right we
may
we are almost certain to be in the dark
about what's going to happen um
but we can at least check in and
talk about what we have discovered so
all right
so forward to that yeah in the meantime
consider joining us at one or both of
our patreons
dark horse membership at mine brett's
ongoing
conversations at his the first of this
month's being tomorrow morning 10
to noon pacific time and
um get outside and be well
yeah be safe we'll see you wednesday
[Music]
you